[Music]
wait wait jamie um before we go into the
most romantic building on the entire
planet
can you just tell me one thing yeah just
you're not in love with lucy are you
why do you keep saying things like that
it just seems like you were really
jealous of her and danny at dinner
okay i'm not jealous of a guy who wears
boot-cut jeans all right see that sounds
jealous lucy is my best friend
next and if i love her it's the way i
would love a sister um i have a brother
and if
she looked at me that way i would have
to talk to her dad next
next let's go lady okay we're trying to
sort something out right now all right
can you just give me a break here just
look into your lover's eyes it's
valentine's day for god's sake
come on quick scenario okay you are on
death row because you murdered a cop
what this hypothetical you could only
say one more person before they
electrocute you who'd it be
my lawyer because i wouldn't do
something okay your lawyer bungled the
case and you have one person to see
before you die
you can say me if it's me
[Music]
it's lucy
i knew that you're good at this it's
lucy
i'm in love with lucy
no no no no okay don't i'm i'm not lucy
oh
no i think it's not it's not like
traumatizing it's okay it's not it's
it's just
i'm okay with it okay folks
next come on let's go i'm a man in love
oh my god jamie this has not been a good
day for you okay
all right i was skeptical about signing
up for cuddle spot but
this is great i am so glad i checked all
ethnicities on my profile
and i'm really thankful that you invited
me up to listen to your awesome jazz cds
yeah and it got me thinking that maybe
we should make
a little jazz of our own
what's the uh rush you know we have all
night
oh i never finished telling you about my
cousin's trip to hartford yeah i don't
have all night though because i need to
get home to relieve the babysitter
otherwise she'll put a ukrainian curse
in me and those work oh
it's just let's just say our first time
making love probably shouldn't be rushed
you know it'll be so much more
meaningful if our hearts connect before
our bodies to
i have never once found that to be the
case let me let me
go first though um
i was bullied in high school
and again in college and then just
yesterday on facebook
my nephew calls me a little pardon
me
[Music]
oh i'm so glad we have a chance to use
these nuts before they go bad
they're a gift from my postman i don't
know why
minnie i think the wine is is ready
if you want to come out
but i think the nuts have turned how did
you know it was here i used the phone
tracker app we have the same password
remember
you share a password damn right we do
it's our dead dog's name
you co-owned a dog josh and wait the
kidney dog she knows about princess
buttercup
princess buttercup is the name of your
dog josh come on great
now i have to change my password oh my
god oh my god oh my god
do you have a key necklace okay she has
a key necklace everyone except
hers is encrusted in diamonds and mine
just features diamonds danny did you see
that okay okay
so this is where you've been on all
those last-minute trips to sacramento
shacking up in the village with some
chubby indian
oh that's that's
you are that philandering gay florist
yeah so what if he is all right at least
he's not some psychotic monster
who crashes the party
and calls a hostess chubby when she's
not she's just normal american
woman-sized and healthy all right this
is a culture of anorexia starting right
here oh i'm so
sorry i flew off the handle when i found
out that my boyfriend of
two years is cheating on me i know
two years way to go josh wait now it's
two years since we met
you ruined my life will you ruin my
party okay this is my home
what about my home you're a home
what is wrecker with you nothing i'm
just fine
that's fine put more water in because it
was dirty anyway josh come here
i was just feeling kind of horny
oh you know what we do that too except
we do it naked this is a family
another homemaker
under different circumstances you too
would have totally hit it off
that's enough that's enough yeah i can
handle this morgan yeah
you know what trespassing is right yeah
i've been charged with it like five
times
not you i just think that everyone at
this party needs to know
this woman sleeps with other people's
boyfriends no no that wasn't you
i actually uh technically
she is right i thought she was the
mistress but
in fact i am the mistress you honestly
didn't know about me
i swear i didn't i guess it was too much
to ask
that i have a great monogamous boyfriend
and that i threw
a great christmas party but them's the
breaks
i'm feeling a little tuckered out so i'm
gonna just uh call tonight
make sure that you take a gift bag on
your way out do me a favor though just
cut
josh's face out of the bag it's no
longer applicable
i'm gonna go drink some uh cough syrup
and i'll see you in the new years
hi i'm dennis i'm mindy i just came from
a delivery so through the sun
raced over well you look very pretty for
having just raced over i just wish that
i had more time you know to get ready
for this date i mean if it is a date
i don't care we could just be heard it's
bros who cares that me
what should i get to eat oh it's a date
oh let's see what
should i order i'm basically a
vegetarian
for moral reasons i mean i eat eggs and
fish and hamburgers
never steak we gotta draw the line
somewhere
wall street huh so you must have access
to a lot of drugs
actually i don't have any access to
drugs on wall street
do you no no no i hate drugs you know i
didn't know that pot and marijuana were
the same thing until college
really okay so we were talking about how
you grew up very handsome and how
difficult that was for you
can i just admit something here carl
warned me that you can be a little bit
not crazy but
dramatic carl said that i will kill
to uh know why you would say something
like that
carl i just think it's really funny
because i find you so charming and down
to earth
thank you yeah i hate drama my
idea of the perfect night is staying at
home yes eating
um salad hello yeah crazy yeah
uh miss there's a boy on the phone named
max he says it's an emergency
i uh respectfully decline he says he's
called you several times
it's the son of a patient you know what
take it by all means
no no no there's a lot of doctors who
can cover me so he's just
so attached to me kids love me
what do you want me to do i don't care
ben just throw it away hang it up
whatever you want to do
it's your phone i don't know
what to tell you can i just give me the
phone
max i am on a date right now do you know
how difficult it is for a chubby 31 year
old woman to go on a legit date with a
guy who needs your economics a duke
hmm i never told you those things i
looked it up online okay
relax please don't pull in my
heartstrings
okay okay okay i'll be there okay damn
it
dennis i've had a great time but i have
to go
oh you know i should be finished at like
two or three in the morning you could
just come over
all right oh no no no no i'm sorry
no i used to be like that really but not
anymore huh not with you
because i'm not no you're great i would
love it okay
at least not first date sure third date
whole other story
really no no no no because you
i like you and what i want to
ruin it with sex okay it's kind of a
roller coaster ride
you